we are just getting the latest
information now on
uh the tiering system uh for some parts
of the country and uh sam coats has more
sam
that's right adam in the last few
moments the government has put up a
postcode checker to find out what tier
you're in
uh so we're going through different
postcodes and i can tell you that
liverpool
city council will be as we were
predicting in tier two the high level
that's a slightly less hype that's not
the highest level but manchester where
indie
rasheed was just uh talking to you from
that will be
in tier three newcastle will be in
tier three uh london boroughs look like
they
are in tier two so the government have
presented it in a format that's not
desperately easy to work out exactly
what's going on everywhere we can't yet
tell whether there's anywhere in tier
one for instance
but the key difference uh at the moment
is liverpool
as the prime minister told mps last
night he's will be in tier two he
believes that the mass testing that's
been going on in that uh
region uh will be uh and has contributed
and has helped
uh enable it go into the less high tier
the middle tier
uh whereas manchester uh is in tier
three the very highest here meaning that
uh
its hospitality uh its pubs and its bars
its restaurants have to close apart from
for delivery and for clicking correct
collect we'll get you more
uh as it pops up birmingham city council
by the way tier three so birmingham is
in the
very highest tier as well you're a
postcode thing there
i have um yeah well just uh i'm going to
talk to some kent mps in a moment i'll
just be interested put in a
kent postcode i don't know i will okay
uh we will do we will do that now
live i think what um uh i think what um
what is interesting about the way the
government have presented it is that
they uh they don't want you to be able
to
um tot up uh exactly what's going on
and how many areas are in tier one uh as
they uh
as they um sort of as they
um as they uh roll it out so that we
can't say
uh that a certain proportion of the
government uh of the country is in a
uh is in a particular uh is in a
particular tier
but uh uh just as we speak of course now
everybody
uh now this website has come up is
trying to get uh uh
their region and uh uh the website has
crashed sorry we're experiencing
technical difficulties
so we'll go through some we'll go
through some postcards and get back to
you